bon
j'appuie
j'appuie pas
on appuie on n'appuie pas qu'est ce
qu'on fait
bon on en rediscutera dans une dizaine
de minutes
en fait quand j'y réfléchis on a
toujours envie de recommencer quelque
chose
est ce que ça ne vous est jamais arrivé
d'avoir envie
de prendre un stylo pour écrire la fin
d'un bouquin qui ne vous aurait pas plu
il d'en vouloir justement à cette
hauteur ou encore de ne jamais avoir lu
ce bouquin
et puis même quand on aime quelque chose
on a envie et cette chose se repassent
recommence
par exemple dans une relation amoureuse
je suis sûr qu'on a tous envie ici de
retourner au premier pincement au
premier frisson
et de manière très paradoxal a contrario
cette même relation amoureuse pour une
raison ou pour une autre
eh bien on va avoir envie qu'elle n'ait
jamais comment cette manière là où
qu'elle n'est jamais fini ainsi et
encore une fois on a envie de tout
recommencer
est-ce que
de manière plus globale dans votre vie
ça ne vous est jamais avons eu envie
arrivé de
d'avoir envie de tout recommencer non
renaître ou encore de ne jamais avoir
vécu votre vie telle que vous l'avez
vécu
et à plus grande échelle encore
qu'est ce que ça ferait pour l'humanité
de tout recommencer
de tous repartir à zéro depuis le big
bang ou la naissance de jésus christ
s'il vous plaît
eh bien peut-être que ça aurait évité
oshima phuket
et l'effondrement des tours jumelles le
pompéi
la shoah sida le coc vide
et pourquoi pas remonter en fait
à cette fameuse météorite qui aurait
causé l'extinction des dinosaures en
fait
parce que c'est vrai que moi ce qui me
préoccupe dans mon quotidien
occupe tout le monde j'espère ici
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que demain je
vais pouvoir avoir des enfants malgré
les perturbateurs endocriniens ou encore
est ce que demain je vais pas de victime
d'un attentat
est-ce que je vais être obligé d'acheter
mon air pour pouvoir respirer
correctement
ou bien
est-ce que je vais pouvoir continuer à
penser et à dire ce que je veux
et bien autant de questions qui pourrait
m'amener
nous amener à mener l'humanité en
général à appuyer sur ce bouton pour
tout recommencer
et puis
si en effet ça permettait de ne pas
avoir connu les guerres les famines les
maladies est-ce que ça permettrait
prêtres ont plus tard été d'avoir
embelli ligne de mire l'extinction notre
magnifique planète
merci moi j'y crois
mais
si on y réfléchit
si on appuie sur ce bouton est ce qu'on
refera pas les mêmes erreurs
parce qu'on se pose toujours toujours
pardon la question pour einstein s'il
n'avait pas trouvé la bombe n'y aura pas
eu tous ces morts
mais vous croyez que les autres ne la
cherchez pas
parce qu'en l'occurrence einstein
a cherché la bombe pour pâques les
salles on la trouve parce que eux
peut-être qu'ils auraient pu faire bien
pire encore
et puis chose importante
là
on est en train de se demander si on
n'aurait pas pu faire pire
mais l'homme
il a fait des belles choses
ces patients un reboot un deuxième
pasteur va exister on sait pas si de
nouveaux on va être capable d'inventer
la radio
l'homme il a été bon il a eu des belles
découvertes des inventions
des larrons jeanne levage
accent
c'est un peu parti pour appuyer mais là
c'est plus
bon reçus entre nous sur le principal et
l'essentiel pourquoi l'homme pourquoi
l'humain désir est il faire un reboot y
appuyer sur ce bouton
bon on a tous ici un ordinateur dans la
salle
et admettons il a un bug ne fonctionne
plus
eh bien
on va tous lui faire subir une
réinitialisation complète
et là tout va fonctionne à merveille
plus de soucis
mais vous allez aussi perdre votre thèse
jolie photo de famille vous êtes en
train d'embrasser votre petit cousin
lors qu'il ya quatre ans
où la jolie formule un que vous avez
décidé de mode il désire solidage
bref vous allez perdre toute votre vie
alors oui je suis sûr que vous êtes tous
en train de vous dire
très bien mais pourquoi mais pas ça sur
un disque dur pour tout sauvegarder une
fille usb
mais non
parce que faire un reboot c'est tout ou
rien
c'est pas sélectionné si nous intéresse
faire un reboot appuyer sur ce bouton
c'est facile tout le mauvais mais c'est
aussi perdre tout le bien
[Musique]
et puis là on est en train de se crêper
le chignon
à se demander
est-ce qu'on ferait pas mieux pas pire
pas moins bien
mais
qu'est ce qui va être là a jugé lui si
ce qu'on fait est mieux ou moins bien
parce que toujours avec votre ordinateur
qui a un souci
vous allez être là derrière votre écran
à juger et à dire oui la géniale qui
fonctionne deux fois mieux oui la plus
black fonctionne trois fois plus vite
mais pour nous en tant qu'être humain
qui est ce qu'il va être là derrière à
juger
personne
si peut-être une idée
intelligence artificielle n'ont
peut-être une idée du contrôle et
montlaur après je ne sais pas si tout
ceci on est prêt à se laisser faire et à
devenir les marionnettes de
l'intelligence artificielle et à entrer
dans la matrice
mais c'est une option
bon admettons qu'elle ne vous plaisent
pas et que vous décidiez de rester un
minimum maître de vos vies de vos choix
de vos actions et donc on ne fasse pas
recours à l'intelligence artificielle
et bien ce serait quand même pas mal
d'avoir du recul sur ce qu'on fait on ne
pas commettre de nouveau les mêmes
erreurs
eh bien ça ça s'appelle l'histoire
et l'histoire c'est aussi l'expérience
ici ont des styles tous ensemble
d'appuyer sur ce bouton onf a décidé
d'effacer l'histoire on va décider
d'effacer d'expérience
donc bon
2 un cul de sac
et puis quand j'ai réfléchi deux minutes
à l'expérience
en fait
je ne suis pas si sûr qu'un humain soit
fondamentalement capable de prendre la
bonne décision au bon moment face à une
situation complètement vierge
en fait je vous dis ça parce que j'en
discutais l'autre jour avec mon meilleur
ami d'enfance confucius
qui m'explique ya un truc de fou avec
une lanterne il me disait ah mais oui ça
me revient
l'expérience est une lanterne que l'on
porte dans le dos et qui n'éclaire que
le chemin parcouru
bon on vulgarise et il réduit
complètement l'utilité d'expérience
en fait ça servirait à masterisé les
situations qu'on aurait déjà vécu
ou les situations qui tendent à du déjà
vu en fait
mais une fois qu'on sent dans l'inconnu
sorte dans l'inconnu et on sait pas quoi
faire
donc bon
notre hypothèse quant à la nécessité
d'une expérience
tombe un peu même voire complètement à
l'eau
creusons nous encore un peu les méninges
pourquoi l'homme pourquoi l'humain
aurait-il besoin de tout recommencer de
tous repartir de zéro de tout refaire
pourquoi pourquoi l'humain désire-t-il
ça
et bien
pour tendre
vers un idéal de vie parfait
sans erreur son souci est que de bonheur
on est tous d'accord non pour que tout
soit parfait
mais c'était à de vie
est-ce qu'on le connaît est ce qu'on l'a
déjà pas le ps qu'on l'a déjà ressenti
mais moi j'ai pas l'impression
parce que l'homme
est un être de croissance
qui s'accomplit face à son environnement
plus ou moins arides l'homme ressent la
jouissance dans la comparaison à la
douleur
l'homme ressent la satisfaction dans son
amélioration on est tous capable ici de
ressentir les eaux parce qu on est aussi
capable de ressentir les bat on est tous
heureux et content quand on a une
meilleure note que la veille pas quand
on a 20 sur 20 depuis le début
fait un reboot mettrai en place un cadre
de vie mais stable monotone alors que
nous en tant qu'être humain on a besoin
de se sentir vivre dans un cadre de vie
évolutif permanent
et puis
ce fait ce fameux pardon c'est à de vie
dont on parle depuis deux minutes
est ce que ce serait pas quand même un
petit peu prétentieux que de se croire
capable de tout faire parfaitement sans
erreur à notre image et en corrigeant
nos prédécesseurs
un peu quand même
et puis en plus d'être prétentieux me
permet
ces lâches et faible que de vouloir
reset le monde parce que si à un moment
ça nous soulage tous ici
d'incriminer les générations précédentes
pour leurs erreurs et de se dédouaner
nous de toutes les responsabilités
c'est parce qu'on n'est pas capable au
quotidien d'affronter le monde tel qu'il
est dans nos actes
c'est donc pour cela que je me tiens
aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est pour ne pas appuyer sur le bouton
parce que je crois parce que je suis
intimement convaincu que chaque jour que
chaque fraction de seconde et la
naissance d'un nouvel objet d'une
nouvelle vie d'une nouvelle machine d'un
nouvel espoir en lesquels nous devons
croire
à nous d'en donner l'orientation et la
signification lesquels nous croyons
puisque l'instant présent et la seule et
unique chose
en les cas nous puissions pleinement
nous épanouir
alors chacun doit chaque jour sans cesse
être le reboot de son prochain merci